[музика]
Вітаю Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа
масові протести в Грузії висвітили
розкол між владою та населенням
тисячі людей вийшли на вулиці столиці
Грузії Тбілісі на знак протесту проти
суперечливого законопроекту про
іноземних агентів висунутого правлячої
партії поліція застосувала водомети і
перцевий спрея протестуючі вигукували
геть російський закон зараз законопроект
знято із розгляду але недовіра
залишилася більшість грузинів хочуть
бачити свою країну в єсенато але вони
сумніваються що їхній уряд може чи
взагалі хоче привести їх туди А
протестувальники побоюються що вплив
Москви зашкодить шансам потрапити до
Євросоюзу
[оплески]
група радикальних проросійських
протестувальників знімає прапор
Євросоюзу біля будівлі грузинського
парламенту і підпалює його ця подія
демонструє політичний тиск під яким
опинилася маленька країна після
вторгнення Росії в Україну багато
грузинів побоюються що їхня країна може
потрапити під контроль Росії тому вони
чинять опір
Ми студенти будемо боротися за
європейські цінності до кінця
Георгій пачоашвілі та тисячі інших
вийшли на вулиці щоб боротися за своє
майбутнє і за майбутнє в якому Грузія
приєднається до ЄС
ми природньо історичні члени
Європейського суспільства і хочемо
інтегруватися до Європейського Союзу це
закріплено у нашій Конституції і з цим
погоджується наше суспільство
ситуація загострилася після того як на
початку березня правляча партія Грузії
про так званих іноземних агентів Георгій
і тисячі інших громадян розцінили його
як удар по демократії вони вийшли у
Тбілісі на протести зіткнулися зі
сльозогінним газом і водометами а
законопроект перегукується з російським
законом який дозволяє уряду
переслідувати критичні ЗМІ Та ндо це
може поставити під загрозу
довгоочікувану кандидатуру Грузії на
вступ до ЄС але прем'єр-міністр
підтримав його
майбутнє нашої країни не належить
іноземним агентам і людям які їм
допомагають
майбутнє цієї країни належить патріотам
така антизахідна риторика нагадує
студентам Московський наратив один із
авторів законопроекту професор який
навчав Георгія чому членство в ЄС
важливе для Грузії аж поки не змінив
свою думку у парламенті
ми бачили що він підтримав цей
законопроект і були дуже розчаровані
цей стало причиною нашого протесту ця
моральна дилема причина того чому ми
відмовляємося відвідувати його заняття
Георгій звернувся до своїх однокурсників
через Facebook щоб оповістити їх разом з
студенти бойкотували заняття професора
вони кажуть що європейські прагнення
Грузії закріплені в Конституції країни і
вони склали її копії перед Кабінетом
професора як нагадування
після трьох днів протестів уряд нарешті
відкликав законопроект Георгій був
стомленим але відчував полегшення
це наша спільна перемога як суспільство
тому що Ми стояли разом
сім'ї друзі колеги і ми досягли цього
разу
студенти пишаються але знають що їхня
країна залишається у скрутній ситуації
війна в Україні щодня нагадує про
складне минуле грузій пов’язане із
Росією 15 років тому коли Грузія почала
зближуватися з ЄС Росія окупувала
південну сесію після п'ятиденної війни
російські війська досі там
грузини пам'ятають війну 2008 року і
пам'ятають історію свого більш ніж
200-річного Московського поневолення
але тут є і ті хто підтримує
антиєвропейські закони
у Грузії повно інно-агентів
не лише ЗНО Але із секретних служб
населення опитування показують що понад
80% грузинів підтримують членство в ЄС
Ми також повинні Пам'ятати про наші
майбутні Битви і завжди бути готовими і
пильнувати щоб ці Свободи ніколи не
відібрали у нас
над парламентом Грузії знову майорить
прапор Євросоюзу але Георгій пачуашвілі
знає що боротьба за його майбутнє в
Європі ще далека від завершення люди в
Україні також борються за своє майбутнє
незважаючи на те що російський президент
Путін продовжує свою війну нещодавно він
відвідав окуповане місто Маріуполь на
оприлюдненому відео видно як він їде по
нещодавно збудованому району і розмовляє
з його мешканцями Це була спроба
зобразити що життя в Маріуполі знову
стало нормальним але це далеко від
істини місто було спустошене після того
як російські війська обстрілювали його
понад 80 днів минулого року і страх
перед російськими бомбами залишається в
багатьох людей в Україні
А ви коли-небудь писали щось настільки
прекрасне що хотіли б зберегти це не
лише для себе але й для майбутніх
поколінь тоді Мартін кунца саме та
людина яка вам потрібна він створює
капсулу часу щоб наші нащадки могли
дізнатися про нас і епоху в якій ми жили
він облаштував сховища глибоко в одній
із найстаріших у світі соляних шахт
поблизу хальштата в Австрії однак дані
для цього проекту зберігаються не в
цифровому вигляді А на керамічних
плитках
Мартін кунца на шляху до своєї скарбниці
сховище з каменю і солі що знаходиться
глибоко у горів Австрії
Він дав проекту назву пам'ять людства
ми знаходимося в зальцбурзі гальштату
найстаріший у світі соляній шахті Ми
спустимося на цьому старому шахтарському
потязі приблизно на 500 метрів глиб гори
ця група гір у верхній Австрії
називається
регіон відомий своєю кам'яною сіллю яку
тут видобувають століттями
старі шурфи та шахти забезпечують
ідеальний захист для архівного проекту
Мартіна кунца дані знаходяться у цих
коробках і з опаленої глини але вони тут
зберігаються не в цифровому вигляді а
Записані на керамічних плитках не схожих
на ті які ви можете купити кунца
випалюєна плитках тексти та зображення
що саме зберігати він обирає за власними
критеріями
Ми принесли ще одну партію плиток вгору
і зараз покладемо їх цю коробку
це частина навчального журналу слюсаря з
1950-х років
тоді все робилося по-іншому
саме тому я вважаю що це варто зберегти
окрім власної колекції кунца також
зберігатиме приватні тексти та
зображення від будь-кого за невелику
плату наприклад історії з часів локдауну
через ковід
або докторську дисертацію пакистанського
дослідника старожитностей який не хоче
покладатися лише на цифрові хмари та
сервери
наш інтернет-магазин такий довговічні як
ми думаємо
це одна з цих причин чому я вирішив
створити цей архів
щоб інформацію можна було зберігати
довгостроково для майбутніх поколінь щоб
вони могли отримати певне уявлення про
своє минуле
вже близько двох відсотків
електроенергії у світі споживається для
зберігання даних
і цифрові системи не вічні їх можна
видалити будь-якою миті або вони можуть
стати нечитабельними
натомість кунца каже що його плитка не
знищенна і уроджена квітня знає про що
говорить
він дипломований фахівець із кераміки і
добре знається на цих матеріалах
Він навіть розробив спеціальний процес
випалювання зображення і текстів високої
чіткості на плитках у своїй домашній
майстерні це займає кілька годин чи
навіть днів
Ця біла глазур плитки з'єднується з
кольоровими гранулами потім вона
охолоджується
після цього виходить гладка поверхня
тому вона така міцна
щоразу коли партія плиток закінчена
Мартін кунце вирушає до соляної шахти у
хальштаті ця мальовничі місцевість
приваблює багато туристів її навіть
використовували для зйомок фільмів
дохаль штату З'їжджаються туристи із
усього світу але мало хто знає що в
глибині гори що над ними вже 10 років
плитка за плиткою росте архів Капсула
часу
ця плитка особливо важлива для Мартіна
кунца вона показує як розтанув льодовик
Всього за кілька десятиліть
це центральний елемент архіву
документування кліматичних змін адже
якщо мене збережемо необроблені дані
спостережень за кліматом майбутні
покоління можуть не зрозуміти що ці
Кліматичні зміни відбулися і безумовно
не зрозуміють наскільки вони були
значними
проект не обмежується лише плитками
разом із Мартіном кунца вчені працюють
над новими матеріалами для зберігання
даних щоб вмістити більше інформації на
меншій площі адже попит дуже великий
навіть у Віденського університету тут є
плитка проект пам'ять людства має
тривати вічну для всіх
ви навряд чи могли б подумати що
найбільше в Європі містечко скалоп
розташоване зовсім поруч із мадридом але
саме Там ви знайдете каньяна-реаль
нелегальне поселення довжиною 14
кілометрів близько 30 тисяч людей живуть
у містечку історії якого налічує понад
півстоліття багато хто живе в халупах
або наметах але дехто побудував постійні
будинки протягом багатьох років можна
владці намагались вирішити проблему
цього поселення тепер місцева Влада
Мадрида планує все знести а мешканцям
запропонувати постійне житло в іншому
місті із водопостачанням та електрикою
пропозиція від якої Навряд чи хтось
відмовиться
цей ключ відкриває Новий Розділ у житті
августини та її родини
є вода
Я маю це побачити
У нас є гаряча вода ми можемо приймати
душ Незабаром у сім'ї з'явиться гаряча
вода а поки що вони досі живуть тут
разом із тисячами інших на старому
скотарському шляху який називається
каньян-реаль вважається що це найбільше
нелегальне Поселення у Європі тут вогонь
на вулиці вказує на точку продажу
наркотиків
лінії електропередач всюди обрізані а в
південній частині деякі жителі також
вирощують марихуану
нещодавно поліція опублікувала кадри
рейду вирощування маріхуани потребує
багато енергії стільки що це може
вивести з ладу місцеву електромережу
багато мешканців поселення кань’яни
реаль приїхали десятки років тому і з
півдня Іспанії або з-за кордону
Августина живе з батьками свого чоловіка
та дітьми у них уже два роки немає
електрики
минуло чоловіка в гостини хоче нам щось
показати
коли генератор працює у нас є світло
плюс мінус
але все ж цього мало
нам потрібно електрика принаймні на
кілька годин для холодильника але зараз
бензобак порожній дорогувато
безумовно
500 євро на місяць за бензин для
генератора
достатньо місця для тварин і невеликий
ринок металобрухту батьки маново
побудували цей будинок і ферму десятки
років тому тоді здавалося нікому не було
справи До поселення на схід від Мадрида
але тепер все тут підлягає знесенню ЄС
надіслав листа у якому назвав
неприйнятним масове знеструмлення
вимагаючи від Іспанії вжити заходів але
мадридський регіональний Уряд не
відремонтував електромережу натомість
комісар поселення запропонував людям
орендувати одну з понад 400 квартир які
придбали місто в обмін на їхні домівки
Але не всі хочуть виїжджати як Сара яка
живе на південному кінці більшість її
сусідів та їхніх домівок зникли
Цей будинок наш
ми завжди платили податки Ми не хочемо
щоб хтось інший вирішував де нам жити
вона показує нам документи які свідчить
про те що вони платили податки на
нерухомість до 2011 року коли Влада
раптово припинила їх збирати сусідка
Сари Елена теж не хоче виїжджати Вона
живе тут уже 30 років і нещодавно
встановила на даху свого будинку сонячні
батареї тепер у неї є світло навіть без
генератора
коштувало мені багато грошей у мене є
всі рахунки якщо Влада відшкодує Мені
все це я переїду майно не моє але
будинок мій
я був мерії більше 20 років тому вони не
дали мені дозволу на будівництво Але й
не заборонили мені нічого не сказали
а відео комісар показує нам супутникові
знімки щоб пояснити чому все так складно
каньян раель утворює смугу довжиною
близько 14 км із 1940 року тут незаконно
зводять будинки за цю ділянку
відповідають регіональний уряд і три
місцеві адміністрації А ще це територія
природного заповідника справжній
містобудівний кошмар але зараз всі
погодилися що Південний сектор селища
має бути знесений без жодної компенсації
цим людям прийдуть повідомлення про
виселення в них була можливість
попросити про переїзд але вони цього не
зробили наступний крок виселення
минуло я Августина вирішили покинути
незаконне поселення до приїзду
екскаваторів маноло виносить все що
можна продати на ринку металобрухту
після цього вони переїжджають до міста у
квартиру яку їм надали Це був момент
коли вони вперше побачили її
[музика]
яка краса
то подивіться на цю кухню
перші три місяці їхні щомісячна оренда
становитиме 50 євро а потім зросте до
200 євро така угода щоб вони покинули
свій незаконно зведений будинок їхній
син ради що їм більше не доведеться
мерзнути і тепер вони можуть просто
клацнути вимикачем і світло увімкнеться
це єдина столиця Європи яка залишається
розділеною ні косія на Кіпрі відколи
турецькі війська вторглися на острів у
Середземному морі у 1974 році кіпри
розділений на території грецької
республіки та окуповану Туреччиною
північну частину багато політичних спроб
об'єднати острів зазнали невдачі але
громадяни продовжують робити все можливе
щоб об'єднати кіпри його жителів як
наприклад йоргос і Мустафа
блок пости стіни та колючий дріт усе це
частина нікосії вже понад 48 років
столиця досі залишається розколотою
поділеною на грецьку і турецьку частини
як і решта Кіпру
греко кіпріоту йоргосуспіро важко
змиритися з політичним глухим кутом із
тим що немає жодної перспективи
возз'єднання
він дивиться на турецьку сторону
пенсіонер каже що примирення більше не
повинно залишатися справою політиків
Я бачу і розумію що якби вони залишили
нас самих Я маю на увазі нас громадян ми
могли б чудово жити разом
і йоргоспіру відчуває наскільки Могло б
бути Чудово У двох общинному хворі Миру
Лєни меланіду
грецькі та турецькі кіріоти співають
разом В ім'я миру та Возз'єднання в
цьому хорі де музика переборює політичні
та мовні кордони
Мустафа ерсалчі співає в хорі вже
півтора року архітектори з турецької
півночі зустрічається зі своїм колегою
по хору йорґосом перед концертом кордон
досі можна перетнути лише через
контрольно-пропускні пункти Мустафа до
цього звик він виріс із цим розділенням
як і його турецькі друзі
коли я кажу їм що співаю у хорі вони
трохи дивуються
але я бажаю Що так ти відчуваєш що робиш
щось для своєї країни для миру для
возз'єднання
коли вони бачать нас на сцені в білому
одязі в кольорі Миру Вони ніколи не
розуміють Хто з нас Грек А хто турок
пісні ті ж погляди
так крок за кроком Я думаю ми впливаємо
на всіх
хто турок а хто Грек Це не має значення
коли хор збирається разом як можна
побачити на цьому концерті миру у
грецькій частині столиці
прихильників Возз'єднання зараз на Кіпрі
меншість але хор не здається і в залі
повний Аншлаг
перед концертом вшановують двох жертв
громадянської війни
1974 року Грека і Турка обидва пережили
масові вбивства ще дітьми сьогодні вони
обидва закликають до примирення
[музика]
разом з усім хором йоргос і Мустафа
виконують пісню Пробач
турецький учасники хору просять прощення
грецькою мовою а грецькі турецькою
[музика]
вони розуміють що одна з умов примирення
це визнання страждань іншої сторони
Ми повинні проводити більше подібних
заходів
і це зблизить людей цінуванні миру та
прощення
На завершення концерту вони співають
пісню
моє коло та на двоє яку з двох сторін
мені любити
обидві ось відповіді куди йти йор-вось
Мустафа та інші учасники кіпрського хору
миру
яка чудова нота на завершення нашого
випуску програми У фокусі Європа цього
тижня Якщо вам сподобалась сьогоднішня
програма ви можете поділитися нею через
нашу домашню сторінку просто знайдіть У
фокусі Європи на сайті dw.com Дякуємо за
перегляди до зустрічі у наступному
випуску
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]